can we talk about sorority or no what
sobriety oh yeah yeah yeah yeah so
because as long as I've known you you've
been in and out right of it well I
started going
um into recovery in 1996
and then I was really in it for a long
time and then I went out for like 13
years wow so it's a miracle that I am
sober now but
um it's just it didn't really like it
didn't occur to me like that it could be
a problem but the thing about like I
have a long history of it in my family
there's a lot of people who have really
bad depression and who have really bad
alcoholism and none of them sought any
treatment most of them just died from it
yeah so it's kind of like uh I didn't
have a precedent within my family to
seek real help yeah but this last time I
had real help and that was really good
so I I think seven years ago your man
yeah seven years did it get bad oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah so I think it was really
um and it's hard to tell if it gets bad
because it's like we live the way that
Comics live is a kind of like Eternal
child anyway like we really don't have
to work that hard or do anything I know
for most of the time
I know I feel bad about it
I feel bad but it's almost like that's
the problem too is that we have all of
this money and then all of this time to
sort of do whatever yeah and then you
can become very destructive with that
yeah yeah I mean I've been like last
night I was no Sunday night I was like I
got nothing to do I'm just gonna play
um Elden ring all day but then around
five I knew that there was a meeting and
you know I'm in in Beverly Hills I'm
like and I didn't even think about I
just kind of got up grabbed my keys and
I went oh good because it doesn't need
to do it yeah because I can't afford to
go back out and it's one of those
feelings where it's like ah if I if I
get into the mind frame of like I could
just go tomorrow I'm [__] so I just go
you know what I mean and I generally I
mean to me it was weird but still I'm
always going I'm glad I'm here yeah
that's good yeah that's good it's cool
do you do meetings still or no I just go
um yeah well I have a regular I have my
regular Clubhouse and then I go
um
to uh very specific ones online so and
then but I have yeah I have a great time
with them I really love them but also
it's like I have to understand that all
this is what I do for a living it isn't
who I am but for many years
if this wasn't going well it would
dictate how I felt about myself and how
I looked at the world I would you know I
would drive down like you know 10 years
ago I would drive down a Sunset and see
my friend on a billboard and instead of
being happy for the person there was
always like you know you know that how
come I can't get it you know I mean yeah
it came back to me yeah and I was I was
like I can't live like that no yeah and
so I've had to change my whole thing and
realize that you know my sobriety and my
family and my friends come first yeah
this is what I do for a living and if
this disappears
it's okay yeah yeah absolutely but it's
so hard when you're you know because
this has been her whole life her whole
lives yeah yeah but it's also you know
the the thing about it is that this
isn't really what makes us happy what
makes us happy is a spiritual life and
that's what's it's got to be about and
then all this other stuff this is just
fun like and like allow it to be fun
yeah and allowed not to get too upset
about it and to think it has to be a
certain way yeah so we don't know how
it's supposed to be yeah yeah and also
um
and I I I I disagree with a lot of
people about this but it's like I don't
know how you feel about it but I believe
just things just happen the way they're
supposed to happen yeah they do it's not
out of my control it is it's totally out
of anybody's control yeah I mean to
control Hollywood is insane there's no
way to do it there's no Rhyme or Reason
yeah it's it's chaos almost to control
anything oh you have to control it to
control it this is the second time I've
seen your dad in a month
oh you saw my brother out the other half
of my dad yeah
so you saw half my dad at my brother's
house yeah and I just like oh [__] yeah
and like yeah when I was there I was
like oh I wonder I wonder if Bobby got